guardian sur scène de 19 à une émission
jean pierre calloch il adore ça et vous
avez des petits de 14 ans moi j'ai
montré gfk présente ça me met les poings
comme ça at on appris de te fais des
films bien sûr mais je vais quand on me
dit l'élu
il est entré par la porte de secours etc
mois qui vient s'il a fait ça ma fille
il viendra ne peut pas parler mais oui
non mais non mais non mais c est donc là
où je suis d'accord c'est bien ce qui
n'est pas normal et facile aux paccots
pas me juger vous qui repartent aux
états unis exercent en plusieurs sur be
quand il dit je vais dans un pays où
coucher avaient défilé par violet couche
avait des filles de 14 ans de 15 ans ce
n'est pas un crime
je disais pays passe aux etats unis
c'est un crime il est fou le mec non
mais oui mais oui d'accord mais c'est
pas sûr que je vais choisir sur moi
c'est une question posée à laurent
seillier ou à quelle peut être qu'ils
allaient cas la réponse de karim
pourquoi pourquoi romane polanski n'est
pas extradé aux états unis pourquoi il
n'est pas jugé
pourquoi en france on le laisse on
laisse vivre tranquillement alors qu'il
a été condamné au 16e je comprends pas
mais pourquoi on se réveille aujourd'hui
la question est là ou non mais pas
aujourd'hui
d'accord mais aujourd'hui si on se
réunit c'est bien parce qu'il ya ce film
qui sort qu'il ya un boycott etc
moi j'estime que le boycott n'a rien à
voir je suis d'accord non pas mal donc
on voit là sur le mollet roth ok mais je
ne me prive pas de dire en ma qualité de
citoyen mais non mais d'accord on
indignation d'avoir nos autorités ne pas
se mobiliser
j'ai la question agace j'aimerais qu'ils
répondent faut-il boycotter
[Applaudissements]
la question est faut-il boycotter
faut-il boycotter romagne bologne
je me permets je me permets une nuance
parce que je pense pas que ce soit aux
cinéphiles ou aux citoyens français de
payer elle vous êtes responsable des
défaillances de la justice je suis un
peu mal à l'aise avec le fait que les
milliers de personnes qui sont partis
voir le film depuis la sortie nationale
hier soit accusé de complicité avec
envers un violeur de complicité envers
un pédocriminels ou de cautionner les
actes immondes de romane polanski je
pense que là on mélange tout je pense
que le boycott n'est pas là les bruits
de la solution je pense le bronze
j'arrive pas à dire le bois coach csb
mavs qui dit soleil un boycott non mais
je pense qu on mélange tout je pense que
les gens qui sont partis voir le film
était peut-être fan de jean dujardin ou
avait peut-être à coeur de rodez comme
chez nous faire important versé cette
année je pense qu'ils vont voir le film
soit complice de quoi que ce soit je
m'adresse pas d'objectif que avec qui je
partage complètement les revendications
mais c'est celle amalgame qui est fait
donc maintenant tous ceux qui vont se
rendre qui vont qui vont te faire le
choix de ne pas boycotter ce film de
payer leur place de cinéma donc de
remplir les poches d'un terreau
réalisateur ou de l'industrie vont en
gros cautionner ce qui se passe c'est
absolument pas le cas
évidemment défaillance de la justice on
l'a noté j'espère qu'on pourra avoir la
lumière là dessus et il ya aussi un
problème dans ce qui est là
la prescription c'est à dire qu'une
femme qui a été violée enfants ou plus
jeunes on peut pas s'imaginer le
traumatisme que celle ci si elle arrive
à se libérer de ce poids
dix vingt trente quarante cinquante ans
après j'aimerais mesures seront assez
tard on doit l'écouter la vraie question
c'est de savoir s'il y avoir une aux
prescriptions non mais voilà dans le
présent mais la loi la loi aujourd'hui
il ya prescription c'est à dire on a
allongé de 10 ans marque
oui c'était 20 maintenant ses 30 ans à
partir de la majorité non mais la
question qui est posée cfoot n'y est
présent mais d'accord mais sept ans
qu'on est dans le droit
on est dans le droit il y aujourd'hui
une prescription je vais peut-être
choquer j'ai pas envie de choquer g
borne et ça avait déjà choqué avec le
boycott
bon faut pas me chercher
et si vous voulez donc à un moment donné
lorsque le délai passé d'un jour je peux
me déclarer coupable d'un crime et être
prêt dans une sorte de virginité parce
que la loi allait comme ça c'est à dire
des fonds le président nomme à la loi
américaine est d'accord mais on vit en
france
inscription nomme il a été jugé par la
mer mais ça n'a rien à voir
dès lors qu'il est jugé dès lors qu'il
est jugé en france c'est pareil il n'y a
pas de prescription sur sur la fuite
la prescription c'est par rapport au
jugement oui donc en l'occurrence sur
les 47 ans a fait 47 ans marwa 43 ans
là il ya rien à faire avec dire qu'on
est dans une sorte de friction il ne
peut pas être passé de vol jets d
affaires sur lesquelles la justice
française d'aujourd'hui s'est rendu à
une puissante parce qu'on a un délai de
prescription
oui mais sur la justice américaine qui a
statué nous pouvons nous domine mais
lorient veut parvenir